alright we've got a few minutes left
here in this presentation and I want to
give you some hands-on nitty-gritty how
to apply the recipe for success to your
business today so a quick recap what is
the recipe for success number one we're
following our passion number two we're
modeling success and number three we're
not going to quit let's dig deep follow
your passion you gotta love what you do
in order to run a successful business if
you try to start a business just trying
to make money you're going to fail it's
not going to happen for you that's a
mistake that so many entrepreneurs make
and it's the number one most important
rule because every other business
strategy that you follow will not help
you unless you follow this number one
rule and you're building a business
around your passion it's so important
and so many entrepreneurs get it wrong
and spend their money and their time
going down the wrong path and end up
frustrated and going back and getting
the job that they hate so how do you
actually go out and build this business
to make it work you have to marry what
you love doing with is what is adding a
lot of value of people's lives if you
love doing something but it doesn't help
people you're not going to make it or if
you're helping people but you don't love
doing it you're also not going to make
it success comes when you can combine
those two things things you love doing
with what is helping people the figure
out that winning business idea you start
by making a list and on that list I want
you to write down everything that you
love to do things you can get lost in
things that when you're doing these
things you lose track of time two hours
go by and you can't believe it this is a
start for me I'd write down things like
meeting entrepreneurs speaking coaching
apply new technology to my business I
love these things I could do it all day
long unfortunately I get to in my
business you want to find the same thing
for you right right down make that list
things you love to do you can get lost
in second thing I want you to add to
that list or think about frustrations
that you've had recently
I got you so riled up so angry that you
had to go out and find a solution there
wasn't anything off the shelf you had to
come up with an answer yourself and you
solved it because chances are if you
went through that frustration there's
lots of other people who are doing it
too and you can help them some of the
best businesses in the world were
founded on a single entrepreneur who had
a problem they solved it for themselves
and then created a solution to help
other people so write those down two
things you love to do and problems that
you solved for yourself now that you got
this list you're going to rank them and
we're ranking them how much we can help
other people again it's got to help
people just because you love doing it
doesn't mean it's a winning business
idea it has to add value to people's
lives if that ingredient isn't there the
business is not going to work so for
every idea on your list what I want you
to do is ranked 1 to 10 in terms of how
much value you think it's going to
provide people 1 being the lowest one is
like you love sitting on your couch
watching TV ESPN highlights ok that's
not adding value to people's lives
that's not a business idea you might
love doing it but it's not going to add
value 10 is something that's going to
add tons of value people find it really
helpful rank all your ideas and from
there you have the base to build
something that can have tremendous
lasting ongoing value and make you a lot
of money ok if you do anything from this
whole webinar that's the most important
question you can ask yourself make that
list and rank them one to ten that's our
start number to model success you don't
have to have all the answers yourself if
you try to come up with every single
answer yourself and do everything
yourself in your business it's not going
to work the business will fail because
you have limited knowledge and
experience you're really good at some
things but you socket other things and
that's okay you don't have to be a
Superman Superman or superwoman to make
a business work the key to making it
work is to model success and we're
finding people who have already done
what we're trying to do and putting
their strategy
to work for us the two key ways to do it
number one look at your industry look at
companies who are in your industry look
at the top guys and look at how they got
started again I looked at Microsoft and
I didn't care how they how they make an
action million dollars now but I want to
know how they got started and I leverage
their partnership strategy and put it to
work for me research these companies
look at how they got started go to the
library look online read books look at
the autobiographies of these
entrepreneurs the bigger the company is
the easier it is to find their story and
we want to find out what they did when
they were in your situation so if your
problem is marketing look at the biggest
company industry and how they got
started and how did they market their
business how did they find their first
customer there's clues there and you've
got to put them to work in your business
because if you try to figure it all out
yourself it's not going to work the
business will not last so that's the
first kind the second kind of modeling
success is to look at what i call
aspirational mentors these are people
who you look up to who have nothing to
do with your business but you just
really like them so maybe it's Donald
Trump maybe it's Oprah Winfrey maybe
it's Bill Gates maybe it's coco chanel
whoever it is that you love and you look
up to that could be an aspirational
mentor for you and whatever problem
you're facing your business look at how
they solved it when they were young when
they were getting started if you're
trying to sell yourself and you love
Donald Trump read books like the art of
the deal see how he closes deals how he
negotiates he gets the best price
possible for what he's doing the answers
are out there and even though you have
nothing to do with real estate you can
still learn a lot from these
entrepreneurs like Donald Trump so don't
let that industry hold you back want you
to do both I want you to find the
companies in your industry and look at
how they got started and then I want you
to look at other entrepreneurs so you
look up to a respect and try to model
their success as well the more you like
that entrepreneur the more likely that
strategy is going to work for you
because you're going to believe in it
you're going to believe that if a work
for reach your brain sort of Donald
Trump it can work for you too
and again these stories are out there go
online read their books the bigger the
entrepreneur is it easier it is to find
their story number three don't quit you
can't quit no successful famous
entrepreneur shut down their business it
comes from taking steps every day and
moving it forward and I know it sucks
and I know it's hard and I know you wake
up some days and you just want to stay
in bed you know the weather sucks
outside you had a bad day before no
customer orders are coming in then you
just don't feel like getting up and
going to work you got to get out of bed
and go to work because if you're not
doing it nobody else is going to do it
for you the cavalry is not coming this
is on you you've got to go make it
happen you started this business for a
reason before before you were running
your business you were doing something
else mm-hmm really had some job right
some job you hate it you they've hated
your boss at your co-workers or the
tasks you're doing you weren't living up
to your potential think back to what
you're doing before you were doing right
now think back to that job think back to
all the painful experiences you had
there because if you don't get out of
bed and go do something today to grow
your business you're going back to that
life and that should be scary and
painful for you and I don't want that to
happen to you you've got to get up every
day and move your business forward I
want you to think about some of the most
painful experiences and use that to
guide you maybe it was your boss
humiliated you in front of your
co-workers or maybe you felt the work
you were doing was demeaning or beneath
you whatever it is make it painful
because that's got to drive you forward
to get up out of bed and go to work and
make something happen today ok the other
thing you can look at is what you want
to be known for what are you trying to
build here yeah you're trying to make
money but what else are you trying to do
you know what do you want your grandkids
to know you for and do you want to live
with the regret knowing that you didn't
give it your all into your business when
Jeff Bezos started amazon com he was 40
years old he was
top VP at his firm he was the youngest
VP ever at that company and he left it
all to go start an internet com startup
people thought it was crazy like who's
gonna buy books online but he said he
had to do it you had to do it because he
couldn't live with the regret of not
trying and that's one of the most
painful things that you can live with is
the regret and I don't want that for you
I don't want you to be in some crappy
job one year from now looking back
saying I really wished I gave it my all
into my business because I hate my life
now and I feel like if I gave it just a
little bit more one more day one more
day one more day it could have made it
happen you should not have any excuse
any crutch for saying that you did not
give it your best into your business
we're bumping up against the time clock
that's it for today I hope you're going
to apply leads us into your business
again I want you to follow your passion
it's so important the number one rule in
business is to follow your passion
number two model success number three
don't quit I want to hear about your
problems I want to hear about your
successes if you want to write to me on
youtube an email on twitter i'm here to
help thank you so much for joining me on
this presentation today and i look
forward to seeing you soon